[Music]
this is an enemy an enemy far more
dangerous than any we've encountered in
battle an enemy that is
Delfy and insidious silent and deadly an
enemy that works in the dark in the warm
moist atmosphere of the tissues inside
the human body particularly in the lung
[Music]
making this enemy even more vicious is
the fact that it selects the majority of
its victims from those who are in the
most productive years of their lives
from 15 to 45
[Music]
and this enemy is tireless unrelenting
this year in the United States it will
kill one person every nine minutes
[Music]
in the three years following Pearl
Harbor this enemy we've been talking
about working quietly at home took more
lives many more than were lost by all of
our armed services on all of our battle
fronts the tragedy is that this horrible
loss of life is unnecessary for this
enemy whose name is tubercle bacillus
can be conquered
tuberculosis highly contagious disease
that this microbe causes is curable well
why aren't we doing something about it
yet why don't we drive it out of America
once and for all
if it's curable why don't we cure it
well as a matter of fact we are curing
it and we have
for example 40 years ago tuberculosis
was the leading cause of death in the
United States
today it is seven in life so you see we
have made progress but we haven't made
enough until recently that is why well
one of the most dangerous things about
tuberculosis is that people are
frequently not aware of it until the
disease is very well at that and it is
in the early stages often before there
are any recognizable symptoms that it
can be treated most effectively so the
problem of curing tuberculosis is a
matter of finding it and finding it
hasn't been easy when most victims of
the disease don't even suspect they have
it until it is really taken hold
[Music]
the most reliable and accurate way to
detect tuberculosis
is by means of an x-ray examination of
the chest but with this being the only
sure method it is not strange that so
many cases have gone undiscovered or a
few of us particularly if we're feeling
all right
ever think of dropping in at a hospital
or a clinic for a chest x-ray and yet if
every man woman and child in the United
States long ago had done just this we
might have tuberculosis link right this
minute well today we are getting
underway with an all-out unrelenting
determination war has been declared on
tuberculosis one of the newest and best
weapons in this war is a type of x-ray
equipment - this truly portable using it
federal state county and city health
departments and tuberculosis
associations are today making it
possible to bring the means for locating
and staring out tuberculosis literally
to the doorsteps of the nation in places
like large industrial plants when a
great many people can be examined at one
time the equipment is set up on the
premises portable x-ray unit will soon
be coming to you here to see just what
happens let's take a look at Aileen
brown a stenographer we find her
entertaining some girls at her home do
buddies good thing about the x-ray
business Aileen red coming home on the
bus it said one of those portable x-ray
jobs to be stationed down by the
firehouse all next week are you going to
have yours taken I guess so
why not it's free and besides I want to
be sure I'm healthy I'd hate to present
Tom with a wife who was anything but
100% perfect when he gets back
come on Joan
here's a snack for to see the body
coming got it mmm
hmm see that was good I thought he'd be
awake all night but I'd love another cup
of coffee no I'm kind of afraid that
x-ray business I'll bet it hurt
why that's nonsense haven't you ever had
an x-ray at the Devon they don't hurt
one of those units came to my husband's
crying about a month ago and he had one
made and he said there wasn't anything
to it it only took a few minutes I'm
worried about another part though what's
that well suppose you do have it doesn't
mean that you have to quit work and go
to a sanatorium maybe get operated on
and well you know that's silly it says
here that if you do have it and they let
you know privately chances are you have
a mild case that can be cured by rest
that doesn't sound very grim to me and
besides if you had it you'd want to be
cured as soon as you could be wouldn't
you and the earlier you discover you've
got it the quicker you can be cured it
okay that sounds like sense to me these
five things you do kid yourself and
don't get it done you don't expect it to
go away by pretending it isn't fair do
you Eileen Brown is wise to realize that
she's doing herself and others of favor
by taking advantage of this x-ray
service left what - she goes through the
procedure
first he supplies certain information
about herself her name address age sex
marital status and so on they're in a
private dressing food he changes into a
cape that has been given her for this
purpose now we're ready for the x-ray
now we'll measure your chest all right
take a deep breath hold it now relax
that's off easy wasn't it it certainly
was well that's as simple as having your
snapshot taken it's simpler you don't
have to worry about the Sun getting in
your eyes sometime later the films are
developed and then examined by a
specialist many people who do not have
tuberculosis have found this free x-ray
examination worthwhile because it has
revealed other chest and heart
conditions that warranted investigation
by a physician of the millions of people
already examined only about 1 and 1/2
percent were found to have any
tuberculosis but it is by finding this
small percentage of apparently healthy
people and curing them that we're going
to control tuberculosis and finally
eradicated
eradicated so that the citizens of a
strong America will be able to enjoy
life to the fullest
and will be able to pass on the
priceless legacy of health to the
generations to come
take a moment
don't you think it is worthwhile for you
to have your test x-ray
[Music]